monorails are almost always bad ideas
the last time i said that i got angry
emails from monreal enthusiasts but
i stand by it yes passenger monorails
are quirky and interesting they
look like something from science fiction
that's why theme parks use them
but they're impractical and expensive
because every bit of track has to be
either elevated
or dug into a trench and switches at
junctions require physically moving the
entire
track there are exceptions of course
there are but for almost every case a
monorail
is a worse idea than light rail or trams
or even a bus and that's proven out by
the fact that almost everywhere in the
world
does not use monorails except
i think i found a good monorail and it
was never public transit
it was a replacement for construction
workers with wheelbarrows the road
machines monorail
was invented in a small town just
outside london in the 1940s it was
intended for construction sites it was
in competition with
tractors and dump trucks and yes workers
hauling wheelbarrows and it's a really
clever solution
the track is made of prefab parts so it
can be set up by just clamping bits
together like a giant toy train set
the company claimed that two workers
could set up 100 yards of track in about
half an hour
and because the track is elevated it
could work over mud and rough ground at
construction sites where
big equipment might get bogged down the
single rail means it can have huge
tolerances it doesn't matter if things
weren't set up precise if someone needs
to set
one piece of the track a few degrees off
horizontally or vertically the monorail
just
clatters through it all and sure yes the
diesel engine
is quite noisy but it's designed for
construction sites
oh and yeah it's automated at the end of
the track
there's an automatic stop built in where
it stops and waits to central its way
again it can even split and merge tracks
easily because
well that's that's easy when the safety
level is designed for bulk goods not
people
by 1966 there were 800 of these
monorails in the uk
some were owned by construction
companies that had set them up and take
them down to each job site some are
installed permanently in factories and
works
they've been sold to 60 other countries
where they transported timber or clay or
sludge or
even at one place in finland fish
basically they could be used to
move any bulk thing that could be loaded
into a wagon
there were versions powered by
compressed gas and a couple of
experimental battery-powered ones
they showed up in a james bond film that
futuristic space age
volcano based monorail was the same type
that was being used in construction
sites around the world just with a shiny
passenger cabin added on top
but now they are almost forgotten by the
70s construction was changing
tower cranes had appeared which meant
that materials could be moved faster and
in three dimensions
across building sites of getting taller
and taller and taller and specialized
dump trucks were improving too
in 1977 the last of the monorails came
off the production line but they were in
use until at least the 1990s
most were scrapped but enthusiasts keep
a few of them running this
one is at the amberley museum in
southern england it's not a regular
attraction at this
enormous industrial museum but they have
run especially for me today which is a
lovely album uh there are also dozens at
a collection in nantmod and north wales
including one that's been modified to
allow passenger rides it's one of their
enthusiasts who told me
about this in the first place thank you
very much to gary it's not that
monorails are inherently a bad
thing it's just that in most cases there
are better solutions
sometimes like here they're the right
tool for the job
thank you very much the ambly museum and
to david voice who wrote the definitive
book on these monorails back in 2011
most of my facts here are taken from his
work so i'll put links and references
in the description
you